good morning believe nation today's
message is find a coach over to you Eric
Schmidt awake mode miss Brazil TV gold
does I receive so many different kinds
of advice I don't know where to start
one that comes to mind is to have a
coach our board member in 2002 John doar
said you need a coach and I said well
out of the coach I'm not establish CEO
why would either coach is something
wrong no no you need a coach everybody
needs coach so though Campbell became my
coach and it served Google very well
every famous athlete every famous
performer has somebody who's a coach
somebody who can watch what they're
doing and say is that what you really
meant did you really do that they can
give them perspective but one thing
people are never good at is seeing
themselves as others see them a coach
really really helps so one of the things
that I've always been a big fan of is
modeling success finding people who have
already done what you're trying to do
and learn from them is one of the
fastest ways people to grow a business
or achieve anything in life because if
you were just trying to figure
everything all out on your own you're
going to stumble around in the darkness
and likely not get to where you need to
go where if you can follow people who
have already done it your path becomes a
lot faster I've done that through two
ways in my life the one is through
modeling masters people who have never
met or will never meet through these
videos to people that I look up to and I
feel like I grow and I learn by having
these people around me so even though I
will never meet Steve Jobs I've learned
a lot from him and by watching his
videos some of that mindset thinking
bigger impact visionary stuff seeps into
me and makes me want to do more the
other is so actual coaches actual people
who have had face-to-face conversations
with I think about in the context of the
YouTube channel my agent in my media
coach Steve and jani were really
instrumental and helping me get better
on camera tell better stories be more
comfortable and I was not a natural if
you go back on my videos we'll see how
nervous and awkward and terrible i was
born at the start and how it's gotten
better and that was from regular
sessions with them especially jani every
week for almost two years going through
and
my videos and give me feedback and how
it can get better so whatever goal it is
that you want to accomplish instead of
just trying to figure everything all out
on your own understanding that somebody
has already done it maybe not exactly
what you do but somebody has done it and
so by mall in their success and trying
to learn and understand from them it can
really short cut your path to
accomplishing that so the question day
today is I'm curious who is your coach
and actually somebody who you've met and
you have conversations with or somebody
that you look up to you as an
aspirational coach who is a coach in
your life that is helping you grow and
what have you learned from them leave in
the comments below I'm going to join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Jamie from relaxing
sleep station calm Jamie thank you so
much you're picking up a copy of my book
really means a lot to me does your
watching you want a chance at a shadow
in the future video make sure to grab a
copy of the book and email in your
receipts when keep track thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and i'll see you tomorrow
morning for another shot event specimen
away expresso give me go